my name is Katrina and I'm interning at
the British Council follow me to see
what my day looks like it's an hour
Bobby welcome to the third floor this is
where I usually work of all me to see
where is it
[Music]
I usually start the day off by the time
the other one is seeking out a number
that you step on you really like the
manoeuvre I really think that I have a
typical day or some days I'm like off
shooting somewhere that mean like
shooting film sorry you know what I mean
right
sometimes in my conferences and times
I'm like taking pictures of people so I
do like a lot of things with all
marketing related I have one tip that I
would say is sometimes like even though
you're tired the stairs are faster I
know there's a lot and the elevators
aren't there but the stairs are faster
so just bite the bullet take the stairs
one of the best things about working at
the British Council is the amazing view
of nothing else than the Eiffel Tower
IRA lady in all her glory that is also
idea let's see what our other into
investments up to whenever not allow
inside view top tips for injuries that
might be with Spencer who don't have a
victim move on cause I don't if I'm on
the bottom up so go British Consulate
protrusion at work you might as well
have a power or solder past - yeah bye
that was my day I hope you enjoyed it
hop in to say hello now it's time to go
home and relax
[Music]